hello podcast enthusiasts out there in
podcast land we'd like to thank bud
light seltzer for being a presenting
sponsor on life is short bud light um
good that's not their motto but maybe it
will be one day we love these drinks and
we can't wait to tell you more about
them but first the show
[Music]
i had several jewish friends growing up
so i got to go to my share of bot and
bar mitzvahs did you ever go to a bar i
went to a couple yeah you don't bother
with it
occasionally
so
later in life i went to another one a
friend of mine uh his sister not my
friend having one
much younger sister had one and
our mutual friend john togo whom we
mentioned a lot on the show he had a
very funny um moment in time uh a
romantic moment with an older woman at
this batman in front of everyone uh it
got very
passionate and she became very amorous
yes
if you picture fiddler on the roof meets
the graduate yes that's what we had
and he has since
gone on he looks a little like a young
dusting off he does he's gone on to find
uh a love of his own yes shout out to
tiffany we both like very much but i
they're very different there's a little
part of me that still holds out hope for
the two of them oh yeah they had a real
connection
i'm surprised those kids didn't make it
shout out to birdie too uh this probably
won't be embarrassing to worry and if it
is we'll cut it out here's the show life
could be a dream
life could be a dream
listening to life is short i'm your host
who seems to be getting worse than
introductions justin long life could be
a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my um
keeping it keeping me honest here's the
show yeah christian doesn't like when i
say here's the show i think it's funny
like once in a blue moon
i don't know why i got in the habit of
saying i don't know here's the show i
mean it's
obvious that it's just a waste of time
it's just like pointless you know what
it is it's lazy
it is lazy for both of us we used to say
it as like after we've we had said
something
maybe scatological
self-deprecating easy way to start the
show yeah and then i just started saying
it
bad habits okay well i gotta break them
first step to break a bad habit is
recognizing it so thank you for uh
helping me recognize that you're welcome
isn't that isn't it nice to hear people
apologize and own mistakes it is nice i
don't get that a lot
in my life uh anyway yeah togo and and
birdie had a great moment back then i'll
never forget because togo is an amazing
dancer and at one point during the spot
mitzvah that he had an audience people
had backed up to watch him like in the
in a movie where there was like a
plethora of middle-aged jewish women all
married
like drooling over him yeah and their
husbands as i recall were all like oh
have fun you know they're all like
drinking
and hanging out with each other um what
a fun day that was and
why are we talking about this particular
bat mitzvah well as fate would have it
uh the recipient of
that of womanhood i guess
right i don't know if that's what that
means yeah means you become a woman but
the recipient of womanhood
with some babies i don't know a little
weird all right well i'll workshop that
um but the
bod mitzvi
the girl whose bar mitzvah was
is our guest today that's good simple
yeah why don't you dress it up
and that was the wonderful the
delightful beanie feldstein beanie fell
to dennis our guest today you probably
knew that already because you saw it
when you clicked on the thing to listen
but i bet you didn't know that we were
at her bot mitzvah
and if you did that means you're uh
either togo or maybe birdie or sharon
feldstein or rich feldstein or you're a
feldstein probably um what a fun family
and of course beanie's older brother
which is how i knew beatty the friend of
the show yeah frank former guest the
show is jonah feldstein hill also known
as hill
um
so beanie was at the time
uh when she had this bum it's but she
was a
bubbly
effervescent she was brimming with like
youthful enthusiasm is that fair to say
you're very fair just this little ball
of of positive energy the bot mitzvah
was musical theater theme yeah i think
all bar and bot mitzvahs have themes
right that may not be true you remember
when max greenfield said that his was
this yeah in life
so maybe that's why i think they all
have themes maybe they don't but this
one did
and it was very
uh they really leaned into the theme i
remember
there was a lot of yeah
she performed and it was it was uh one
of the more
one of the more entertaining
nights of my life i would say yeah and
beanie had um there were playbills from
all of beanie's plays that she had done
in school i remember she
lining the walls they had like um they
had like an awards room
before they ever won awards you know
those kids they were like
really into if beanie much more than
jonah jonah wasn't really like a showbiz
kid jonah's thing was he wanted to be
which he talked about on the show he
wanted to be a writer you want to write
for the simpsons
but beanie was a real i mean it's not at
all hard to see
how beanie is where she is now as an
adult she's uh she has become like a
broadway
performer and now a uh a movie star but
he's a movie star she you may know her
from
such films as lady bird
and book smart olivia wilde former guest
the show yeah um should we have to say
that every time we mention uh i think so
yeah i think it's nice too they're like
part of the part of the fan show now the
part of the fam life is short fam uh so
beanie is putting some great movies uh
yeah neighbors too lady bird oh yeah
neighbors too smart and now she is in a
new one called which we i saw right
before i talked to her
called how to build a girl so good it is
really good uh check it out it was um i
think ifc released it but you can find
it on those
streaming
streaming streams streaming but first
listen to uh our ketchup sesh because i
hadn't i didn't talk to beanie in a
while uh let's just get into it my
ketchup with the joyful the mirthful the
very talented beanie feldstein
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
how long have you been there at casa
feldstein
not well this time or in my life
well yeah
this time uh over nine weeks
how's it going
how is it yeah are you okay you know
i live in new york city usually with my
best friend melanie who's been my best
friend since we were 12.
and
i was supposed to move out to la to
start something here in march and then
this happened so i was planning to move
for like only you know whatever six
seven months but i've been planning to
come out here anyway and then
i just decided to to keep that sort of
plan um i wasn't planning to live with
my parents during filming that but right
right
yeah it just worked out that way it just
worked out that way was that the monica
lewinsky movie it's a tv show but yes
that we were supposed to film but we
have not started yet okay all right
where's jonah then jonah's at his house
yeah so his house that does not our
parents he does not live with our
people right no i know but have you been
seeing him are you able to see each
other we haven't been in the same house
at all but we have been very careful so
we'll go and like sit our car outside
and like wave to him but we have not
been in the same room in wow
yeah wow well so it's it's just you [ __ ]
it's you shane rich me shay rich and
jackie the dog oh my god
have you had to drop like different
rules i mean are there any different
guidelines that shea has to follow oh
well shea is my mom but she's my dad and
shay
is as justin knows one of the most
i always say thank fran drescher and
you're like 70 there
yeah and it's like 70 fran and like 30
insane magic mania that does not exist
for anyone else but
she is a magical creature from the
heavens she's a full queen but she's
also i also call her lord annoying like
her full nickname is lord annoying
yeah
yeah that's funny like i'm like lord and
so the i will say like the day time
i'm like screaming at her to be quiet
because she'll walk around the house
with her air pods in on conference calls
and she'll just stomp around from room
to room and i'm like you have to pick a
room like you just simply have to pick
room i'm i'm doing work calls i uh i
have a new movie that's on demand so i
was doing like interviews and that you
know something like this so i'm like
shae gotta pick a room girl we have to
just pick one room
but then at like six o'clock
i'm like
she is so overwhelmingly like
she's fun she's such a great hang um she
but i can also see it
it can be troublesome um it's funny when
you mention fran drescher i
she's always reminded me obviously of
shay and uh so when i
fran was playing my mom in this thing a
couple like a year and a half ago two
years ago my god yes and there was did i
tell you this do you know this i know
the story but you have to tell well well
so i i mean
i just assumed there was this part of
fran drescher's sister so my aunt in the
movie and um and they were like the
director asked me if i knew anybody and
of course i was like do i
you know i was like oh my god
i just so i texted sharon about it
veni's mom and i just assumed she would
like
leap at the chance i don't know why i've
just always thought
she was a performer you know she's so
she's such a like presence
i just thought she was really delved
into this during quarantine actually
justin and
really like
jonah was phase 10 we asked him you're
talking and we like really thought it
through like would she be a good actor
and the answer was like she literally
would be the worst actor of all time but
this is interesting she cannot
read let alone memorize lunch she can't
read the lines
and she doesn't remember what she's done
like continuity looking into the camera
like all of those things because she
needs to be free to be shay yes yes you
know what i'm saying she can't be
someone else like that we really thought
it through we were like she just simply
can't be anyone but shea if she's
playing herself honey watch out oscar
here we come she knew that she wouldn't
be able to do that when she texted me
back she was like
it was such a surprise but the more i
think about it and like you're totally
right she would be she has to be
unfettered sharon has to be like it
would just constrict her to have to say
certain words you know
exactly but a close second was um she
said so she suggested birdie who's my
mom's best friend since they were eight
yes i think eight or nine yes so
birdie and this all connects to beanie
because um
i don't know if you know this part of
the story is that at your at your bad
mitzvah which i had the best time at my
friend john togo
john and bertie who i always thought was
your aunt for some reason she basically
is i mean she's not technically but when
you you know 60 years of friendship um
not quite but almost 60 years of
friendship with someone makes i feel
like your sister's at that point yeah
but bertie and togo had a very
amorous connection
your button it was so weird uh i won't
get into it anymore than that but um uh
we always laugh about that and bertie
ended up playing the part she played
fran drescher's sister she was great you
made her whole life you made her entire
life it was good for us she helped the
movie out um
i you know i don't know if i know this
being where did the name come from where
did beanie come from um so i was given
the name elizabeth that's like what's on
my birth certificate elizabeth greer
feldstein
and when i was a baby i had a caretaker
who called me elizabenie
from like a month old not even um from
my literal birth of she would just call
me liz beanie and
my brothers thought it was really funny
and they just started calling me beanie
so from the time i was like
three months old i mean i've watched
some home videos there's like a mixture
of elizabeth and beanie for a couple
months and then it sort of starts to
just be beanie so i always say like if
you call a dog spot but you call it
spike it's just gonna think it's famous
but like it doesn't know the legality of
things
like for me i was just like i think it's
beauty like i didn't i didn't have any
and then eventually obviously i was told
and i remember every day i mean
literally through college on the first
day of school i had to remind myself
like truly be like being remember to
raise like when they take attendance you
have to say like i'm elizabeth but can
you please call me beanie but it it
literally up until my 22nd year of life
i had to be like just remember that you
have to listen out for that name because
it's so not
in my
instincts like just like your natural
instincts that you learned growing up of
to listen to when you're called and all
you have to do is like i'm not being
like rebellious and it's not that i
don't like the name but i don't remember
to listen for it so even i swear my
senior year of college like at a new
term i had to be like they're going to
say let's put you up remember yeah it's
weird that's so funny that they wouldn't
so you just never went through the
protocol of like changing it officially
so it's not on your
no bureaucracy and like authority really
scare me and i find it very intimidating
so the idea of like the paperwork
involved to change
my my driver's license yes you're like
all of that just seemed really
intimidating to you i've never done it
although i feel like the thrill of being
able to say like that's my real name
would be very exciting yeah so maybe
i'll do it
eventually i know that's one of the few
luxuries i allow myself is once i made
some money i i just got a business
manager to do
everything i just i it makes me really
uncomfortable uh handling money or
anything like that i was born with one
which was right yes
my dad is the opposite of everything we
said about my mom the literal
exact 180 opposite um he is quiet and
pragmatic and
grounded and that's true not very social
and
um but he is a an accountant so i did
have the luxury of someone to help me
with those things growing up how are
they socially like when you go to uh i
mean i imagine i know how sharon is but
at like a cocktail party is rich just
like
i have a great example okay
which is i um i grew up doing musical
theater i obsessively and i did every
musical at community theater and summer
camp and um at my high school and so my
senior year of high school
i we did pippin and my parents were
waiting in the lobby to go take their
seats at pippen and this other mom of
someone else in the show who i had done
many shows with came up to my my parents
and she starts talking to my mom and she
was like beanie i mean uh sharon i just
want you to know that like the way
you've raised beanie by yourself has
been just so incredible like
for you to go at it alone
i just wanted to say she's lovely and
she you know she's going on and on and
my dad is literally standing directly
next to my mom with his arms crossed
just smiling and laughing and and she's
like and my mom was like this is my
husband
and he's like hello nice to meet you it
didn't bother him at all but
that has happened so many times
throughout our lives just because being
just because he's not like a presence
like uh he doesn't make his presence
known oh no shay is like a bulldozer
like she's just she you know and that is
her magic in the world but my dad is so
just like we'll take a backseat quiet
you know not gonna rock the boat i
wonder if your mom being so extremely
the other way
he's adapted to the point where he's
even more reserved and withdrawn
than even his in his name so my parents
met at summer camp my dad
they were both teenagers but my mom was
13 when my parents met my dad's ability
rich was a counselor right yeah i didn't
want to say it but you
i'm always like sick like the idea of
that is
sick but yes my dad was the counselor
for the boys side my mom was a camper
and
my mom told us yesterday that she like
aggressively went after him classic shay
and
yeah well yeah you could have imagined
that
duh yeah um they've been together i mean
pretty much ever since they took like
maybe like a few six month breaks or
something over the course of until they
were like
18 or 19 and then they they got married
super young
so they've been together basically their
whole lives and so i'm sure they've kind
of
gone in extreme opposite opposite
directions because they have the other
one to balance them out for sure do you
remember what it was about
theater or musical theater i of course
remember we were just talking about
that there was like a shrine
to be i remember jonah being like my
sister loves
well it was like playbills everywhere
and and you had the the one thing that i
learned about you early on is that you
had a
it's like an understatement to say that
you loved musical theater obsession so i
think the first thing would be my mom
sat me down and i watched funny girl
when i was a toddler
like only my mom would do that
but she's like this is a funny jewish
girl that you were going to watch and
you were going to love
i became obsessed with barbra streisand
and funny girl in particular and i would
run around my house um screaming don't
rain on my parade and like pretend that
my you know the kitchen chair was like
my tugboat and i was doing the whole
thing but something to that i don't know
i don't know if we've ever talked about
is that i had nodules on my vocal cords
as a kid so even as like a toddler i
sounded like this and i would talk to
everybody like this and so when i say
scream it was because i couldn't really
sing
and my mom you know my parents took me
to the doctor i sounded like a smoker at
like a year and a half but yeah
literally and and they were like you she
has little like nodules which are
basically like blisters on your vocal
cords from your from your vocal cords
coming together wrong like rubbing and
um they were like she's nodules but if
she's not going to be a singer like
she'll just grow them it's fine it
doesn't matter and then i fell in love
with musicals so i started doing
musicals but i still was very raspy's
kind of carol king sounding wow and then
at nine i came into my mom's office and
i remember i just had no voice like i
was opening and closing my mouth but no
sound was coming out and it was
so scary
so
i went back to the doctor and he was
like they're very severe and i i just i
this is what i wrote my college essay
about i just like fell to the floor and
i was hysterical and i was just like
this is what i want to do this is who i
please like you have to i need this
right yeah i have to do this um it's
like you know uh a figure skater or a
olympic found gymnast like breaking her
ankle in a secure way you're like you
have to fix this you have to get oh my
god me back so i went to speech therapy
and i
re-learned completely how to speak and
then i eventually relearned how to sing
which is why i speak really high like i
have a very high speaking voice and it's
because they've re-taught me how to
speak and
and speaking higher is much better like
for your vocal health so all these
things but i think it was that i mean
when that happened
obviously i was like this is who i am
like you can't take this away from me
it's so dramatic sounding but it really
kind of set the path that i was like
this is totally gonna do and also being
able it must have really illuminated
like
out of in in a dramatic way that
is what a test what a litmus test for
what you really
care about and and
when there's the prospect of that going
away from you definitely i feel so lucky
i mean
to have a passion in general but like
specifically to have found it at such a
young age like a ridiculously young age
to know like at nine i mean some people
don't find who they are their passion or
what they want to dedicate their life to
until they're
you know many different ages throughout
their lives
so to know that young like this is who i
am this is the community i want to be a
part of this is what makes me happy i
don't know i just feel like that is a
real gift i'm so grateful for that
knowing you we were in our i was in my
20s and jonah wasn't quite a bit older
than you but to us it was always kind of
charming and funny that this young
person this kid
had such a and a clear idea of what they
wanted to do
that's why i think i really
love hearing about your success and when
you
you know and seeing you in things now
and i i don't know it's it's it's really
nice because i saw
how much you loved it uh even as a kid
it was so apparent it wasn't it was nice
it's nice to now see it come to fruition
i dreamt my whole life obviously of
being on broadway that was all i ever
ever wanted to do was to be on broadway
but when i was doing community theater
or even school theater like the stakes
felt just as high totally i was
committed just as much
it's still that rush that feeling of
commitment that community feeling of
like a cast and creating something
together
everyone thinks this is crazy because
jonah was doing movies by the time i was
in my my like middle school years but i
never
envisioned myself ever being on screen
because i couldn't practice it
whereas i felt like i could i had
practiced theater my whole life so i
knew somewhere inside me that i could if
i could just be given the chance i could
try to be on broadway because i had done
20 musicals and i knew what i was doing
you know you had to wake the wings and i
knew that makes sense you know and
with film or television it felt like
this mystical thing that like you can't
emulate you have to just be doing it
in order to do it and that i don't think
as someone who's kind of a type a and a
perfectionist i it really intimidated me
i was like how does he know how to just
do it and i think that is jonah's gift
is he's so
instinctual and he's so kind of
naturally brilliant whereas i'm like a
woman of a girl of practice like
that's interesting i really needed to
learn well that's that's interesting
that you say that because it's
especially musical theater too i it
makes sense it's more of um there are
tools
that you need and you need to like you
said it's it's you need to exercise
those
those tools um
and i think probably from your
experience the fact that you had to
retrain yourself and you had to be so
disciplined about that it must have only
reinforced that idea that like this is a
pursuit this this is something that you
have to really
hone and craft and
um but didn't jonas
doing movies didn't that kind of
demystify it in some way like uh no i
feel like it only it only remystified it
i wish that's not a word but now it is
also i was 12 so i was yeah he's an
adult
with a career and i'm gonna go to you
know geometry now he's my favorite
person so like that it was only nothing
but positive but it definitely felt like
jonah's an adult and he goes and does
this very amazing kind of mystical thing
that involves a ton of people on a set
and he can come up with jokes and he's
so funny and he does this thing and i'm
just gonna go to tap you know what i
mean yes yes yes
i'm gonna work that makes sense being
because also what jonah does do
most of his gift you can't really teach
i mean like
i think the most impressive thing about
jonah is something that you
you witness when you go to a like a
group dinner with him i remember
introducing him to people that were
actors that i would have been so
intimidated by at his age and he just
would turn it on and i could see him
charming people with his wit and his
sense of humor i mean he was just like a
very
that no he's effervescent in a in a very
specific way and i think what we were
saying about my mom well i still don't
think i'm funny like and my family jokes
with me that i'm not that funny even
though obviously i've been in comedies
like
i'm not the funny one in my household by
any stretch of the imagination like i'm
sort of middle of the road and so i
think it's that more kind of
apprehensive grounded pragmatic side
from my dad that i am not sort of the
creative spirit that jonah and my mom
are in some ways my favorite thing about
jonah is that he's always willing to
learn
he's so open and he always wants to
better himself and he so wants to learn
and i think that he is so charming but
he also wants to know people because he
wants to like soak up their knowledge
yeah that's i think why we became
friends we he i loved his curiosity but
and he it's funny on this on the podcast
he
uh that's how he spoke of you in that
context in in someone who is uh always
willing to teach him and teaches him in
a way that doesn't come from a place of
judgment or um
so i was so i don't know moved i
people always ask me what i learned from
him or like if we talk about the
business or whatever and we're always
like i'm always like we just heart to
heart like we just get mushy like we're
just
that's who we are i mean i i love his
advice and i often ask for it but it's
more just like mushy heart to hearts all
this yeah that's what it should be
that's whatever we're together life
could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
you're in high school you're falling in
love with musical theater um at what
point do you think uh i want to pursue
this though i mean when does it change
well it's so interesting like i sort of
never even thought about it it just was
always very clear to me like even
i think i came out with jazz hands like
i was just like here at you know a
three-year-old obsessed with barbra
streisand and did five musicals a year i
went to i went to a normal summer camp
but i also ended up going to a theater
summer camp i just surrounded my whole
life by
my whole year my whole kind of
experience of my life by theater people
that love theater doing theater
singing dancing all of it
that it was actually
a choice when it came to deciding what
to do about college
that i went the opposite way which was
i felt that i had been so lucky first of
all it's so lucky to have an arts
education in general so many people
don't get that and i had
so much of it growing up that i felt
that i didn't
i hadn't explored the academic side of
myself enough i went to a super rigorous
high school like obsessively rigorous
and intense and competitive academically
and
i
didn't always apply myself because
sometimes it hurt too much to apply
myself and then not succeed
and i felt
stupid sometimes like i did not feel
smart
and so i think there were moments
throughout my adolescence that i was
like if i'm not gonna hit them i'm not
even gonna try and i'm just gonna putz
around and i'll do anything and
i don't know i was such an academic kid
and i loved school and then i sort of
hit this wall where i was like i'm not
as smart as my friends i'm not as smart
as the rest of my class
i don't know what to do and then towards
the end of high school i found my way
back again
and i
started applying myself and getting
great you know much better grades and
and then so for college
there was an infamous meeting with my
college counselor that me and my parents
were talking about the other night which
is my mom
completely was convinced i would go to a
bfa program major in musical theater and
my dad was like absolutely not and we i
think the whole school shook we were
screaming at each other so loud in this
tiny office of my college counselor and
i was hysterically crying and screaming
because i felt kind of
caught between two worlds and i ended up
making the best decision i've ever made
which was i went to wesleyan university
in connecticut and an amazing school so
um
i mean such a beautiful commitment to
the arts
but
it is somewhere you get a bachelor of
the arts you're not it's not a
conservatory but there's so much art
happening on the campus that it was the
perfect balance and i ended up majoring
in sociology
which oh wow i remember calling my
parents and my shay was like what what
is that even what and i was like i don't
i is that is that like you want to go to
parties yeah she's like you're social
you're learning to be social okay um
but i
i just i don't know i felt like there
was this academic side of myself this
this
commitment to my own intellect that i
had kind of given up on and then refound
i'm so glad i did it it changed my brain
it changed who i am as a person it
changed the way i am now in this
industry because i socially set scripts
and stories to i think higher standards
than i ever would have known to before
kind of going on that academic journey
and i want to put things into the world
that are
helping or shifting society in some way
that are good in some way and i i think
i crafted that morality during those
four years at school when it comes to
wesleyan i also think about how
important it probably was for you to
meet ben platt your still dear friend
actually we met in middle school at a
thought mitzvah of a beautiful friend
our our friend allen adele and she was
like oh you two at like the kind of
pre-party whatever it's called the
cocktail hour we wrote she was like you
two love theater and we started talking
and we never went into the party we just
sat outside the party and talked about
musicals for like three hours but we
didn't have cell phones um i think maybe
i my mom let me borrow her cell phone
but i didn't we didn't have our own cell
phones
at that time so we didn't i mean it's so
crazy now to think like if two teenagers
or middle you know middle schoolers meet
they're just immediately friends on
everything oh my god all day long but we
were just on that cusp so we didn't have
phones and we didn't have any uh social
media or anything so we were just like
nice to meet you good night and then
he came to my school he joined my school
in ninth grade and we
walked in you know the first day of
ninth grade and i was like ben
oh my god and he was like penny it's so
nice to see you and we had the same
lunch period and that was it we've been
inseparable wow ever since so you did a
lot of theater together in high school
oh my yes we were sky and sarah and oh
man girls i was completely miscast i
should have been adelaide but somehow i
ended up as sarah or or just neither of
the two but i'm certainly not a sarah um
but we were a little red in the baker
and into the woods
yeah beanie i just loved hearing you
guys do that song from the baker baker
and the baker's wife and into the woods
that was really beautiful oh i loved
that so much that was such a beautiful i
don't know i felt like if i could have
told
my nine-year-old self that i would be
singing for steven sondheim and he would
hear it that a
and b like with that lineup of those
performers that i have grown up on and
idolized and worshipped my whole life i
just it's still kind of a surreal and
with ben and doing into the woods oh my
god together it's so surreal but it was
so special your nine-year-old self
probably would have fainted if they had
known they were going to work with bette
midler i mean that too is like that's
like that's like barbara level i mean
you grow up uh female and jewish there
is no one like bette midler
it's i'm studying yeah you're literally
still like i i know her personally i
mean you're still lost for words i'm
still literally unwell um
my mom actually this is not to focus on
every time i lose my voice but when i
was oh i just graduated from college i
had like another little vocal scare and
i was on voice rest and it was right
around my birthday and my mom had gotten
me tickets to go see bet like for her
and i to go see bet in concert in new
york and i couldn't say anything because
i was on voice dress because i i had
like another little vocal injury but i
just my mom was like you just were all
eyes you just watched and you like
mouthed along to every lyric
she did this huge incredible show
i filmed like all of it i was crying was
like the best birthday gift i'd ever
been given
and
a year and a half two years later i was
in the rehearsal room with her like it's
completely
surreal like completely and utterly
surreal
she is heaven so you were able to tell
her you were you were able to like
properly express i wanted to play it
semi-cool right you can't do it right
away
we're talking about hello dolly and the
entire cast was announced
well first they announced that bet was
coming back to broadway as dolly and i
defied and like tweeted about it was
like this is the best thing to ever
happen to my life as an audience member
and then they announced the entire cast
like everyone working on the production
creative team et cetera and then at the
bottom it was like minnie fey to be
announced at a later date but they had
the entire like 40 person cast oh wow
set in stone but they still hadn't found
a minnie fay and then i was doing i was
filming lady bird
and we were doing the scenes where i
sing in the in the film
and our producers were also producing
hello dolly and they thought well
i don't know why don't we give beanie a
shot
and i auditioned very strange for
broadway not an um it's such an
avant-garde experience i i auditioned in
la because that's where we were filming
with a casting associate and a pianist
that's it like no creative team no dance
call because they were really down to
they had announced the whole cast they
were rehearsing in like the next month
and
i auditioned just in a room the three of
us and i sang elegance and i did the
monologue
and then i came home to this room
because i was staying with my parents
during lady bird
working as a local and
i you know i was like anything to be a
part of that movie all right i'll stay
with you
and
i was in this room and i got a call from
my agent and he was like i was like oh
does the tape not work like they
something messed up the audio on the
tape i have to drive back and he was
like you got it and i was like
i don't understand what you're saying
like i thought i was literally i was
like i actually don't understand what
you're saying you're lying and i just
kind of like got angry it's not a funny
joke i was like this is not funny you're
lying to me
and then when he kind of eventually
convinced me i was screaming my dad
richie cried richie cried
my mom cried we were just a magical
moment in my life
and i remember awesome yeah yeah it was
yeah and bet the greatest lesson i've
learned from her
is to never stop working hard
because she works harder than any other
person in the room in a way that is
insane like you have to as you know you
do so much theater you have to have an
equity break like per the union you have
to break for 15 minutes every hour
they're very serious about it to the
minute three hours four hours equity 15.
and
that never sat down like she'd be
rehearsing choreography she'd be
figuring out exactly how to take her
jacket off in the exact way that would
make it the funniest she would figure
out how to open and close the door to
the set to give it the biggest punch she
never sat down she's bette midler she
was 71 i believe when we started
rehearsals turned 72 throughout the run
and
that was i mean she's the funniest
person to ever walk into a room i mean
she's so
there's more comedy in her pinky finger
than in my entire body was she always
cracking jokes was she always
just
she's not doing bits she's just the
funniest person you have the funniest
thing to say
tough as nails
she just led by example in the most
remarkable way and it was my broadway
debut i was 24
23 when i started and i just thought
well this is it you get to watch batman
we're in the rehearsal room yeah where
do you go from there
you don't go anywhere really does it
you're just kind of
so great
um and then and also a lot of like
really brilliant female performers
directors uh greta gerwig you mentioned
on lady bird you got to work with uh
olivia wilde i mean they're two of the
best two of the best directors period
working how were their styles compare to
one another how do they contrast would
you say
oh that's so interesting i don't know if
i've ever been really asked that
i don't know it's so hard it's also
unique in that greta wrote the script
herself and then directed it
um whereas katie
soberman are
one of my dearest friends who is beyond
brilliant her and olivia their
collaboration was so beautiful to watch
whereas
you know just a completely different
process because you're collaborating
between two people and then like doing
something by yourself
greta changed the course of my whole
life like truly changed my entire life
that movie changed my life it changed my
career but it also just changed who i am
as a person i think it ought to be too
grandiose but like no house how so
she's just the most thoughtful
giving person and writer and director
and her movie that she made that i got
to be a part of
showed me that there are stories that
meaningful that could exist to me
if i had encountered that movie not as
the person who played julie but as an
audience member as a teenager
it would have
completely altered the way i felt in the
world i think
and i don't know i mean because musicals
have their own thing and they're larger
than life in their own ways
i just didn't know that a story i could
be a part of storytelling in a way that
could like pierce my heart so much
i remember
reading the script for the first time
before i even got to i mean i knew i was
reading it to play to audition for julie
but before i even got to when julie was
introduced reading that scene of the two
of them in the car
i of lady bird and her mom in the car
just that's really beautiful what is
this how yeah how does this exist and
how am i getting to read it and then
you know and then i flipped a few more
pages and it was like julie
chubby loves her friends loves theater
like hard on her sleeve and i just
was like
what
this is this is too
this is too good to be true i don't
understand how i'm getting to read this
right now and i
i auditioned with greta she read
ladybird and i read julie and i remember
saying to myself just
listen because she's willing to read
with you just listen yeah and i think i
don't know i i always am kind of
self-conscious that that's not as my
best skill as an actor and i just was
like just listen bean just listen and i
remember skipping out of the audition
room i've never skipped out of anything
and i was just light i was like floating
i ran into one of my best friends from
wesleyan on the street and i was like
cape hi
huh and he was like what is your ugly
and i was like i don't know it was
something amazing just are you on
crystal meth yeah literally he's like
petey you've never done drugs what did
you do at like 11 a.m on a tuesday
if never you know you went to wesleyan
without smoking weed and somehow i feel
like you're altered right now
she just changed she set the precedent
for what i wanted my career to be
because you just felt so good you just
felt like you had you had nailed it i
just was skipping because i just felt
transformed by reading with her i felt
like yeah i was talking to my best
friend but obviously i'd never met greta
gerwig before but we were just
i think that the greatest gift both of
them have ever
and and cokey who directed how to build
a girl too but with greta and olivia
they set us up for success they created
a space that was so warm and so safe
that
you just couldn't help but do your best
because that's what was being
you were just so taken care of sure you
trusted them because
i trust them with my everything and i
would jump in front of a car for both of
them i think hopefully they won't ask
you to do yeah i hope not i mean maybe
not today but
i i think the biggest difference would
be their energy like greta has a calm
kind of
uh kind of
a calm laser focus energy yeah olivia
has
a uh excuses yeah she is like a fiery
laser focused energy she is yeah she's
so full of life and she's like jumping
around and her every day was like a
different amazing sneaker that she would
wear and we shot at night and it was
just she has this like fiery fun energy
that is electric whereas greta has this
like grounded quiet focused energy that
is electric but the way their energy
manifests i would say is very different
that's the biggest difference but yeah
but still uh a passion like they're
still exhibiting a passion god yeah they
both have tunnel vision but
sort of quiet and lives is like sparkly
kind of
she's so she was so confident and her
confidence was infectious and it made us
feel confident and when she
said
we have it we're moving on with like a
smack and like a
you know like a fist in the air you're
like yes we got it we're moving on you
trust her whereas whereas with greta
it's like this much quieter kind of
gentle energy but with that same
feeling of confidence and trust she was
so emotional behind behind the camera
she was really with us in the scene and
i
i don't know she would cry and she would
laugh and she was so
she was like a participation
yeah so getting in that way and it's
like being what you said about jonah
like how he is he has like this
insatiable curiosity and he collects
things he's like a great collector of uh
things that he admires and so that's
probably what made i mean mid 90s i
think is such a good movie i think is
such an impressive debut for a director
and it's and it's like you said he's
been soaking up
and just mining all this information
from some of the best directors
right right right he could
literally recite you every episode of
the simpsons i think for the first 25
seasons like yeah yeah
he was obsessive about music and about
skateboarding and movies and it's so
funny because i'm obsessive too but i
was always obsessive about musicals yeah
so
i'm i feel like i'm on the past five
years that i've been making being a part
of making films
i feel like this great student i'm like
i know nothing please teach me
everything yeah it's exciting because
jonah is such a cinephile i am sort of
like it makes me embarrassed sometimes
or nervous or anxious that i am i didn't
grow up that way and so this is a brand
new journey for me and i don't know i
asked ask any camera department i've
ever worked with i'm like why are you
putting that on now why are you moving
that right it's gonna be you do and why
is that and it's like i just want to
learn i just totally learned more well
it's also probably served your
relationship and i probably made you
guys closer uh and he
alluded to this is that because you're
into such different things and because
your the age disparity was such that
like there was never like it wasn't like
competition he was like she was just
this adorable little you know
what did he want to see a basketball
with eyes
yeah basketball with arms
honestly still true still a vibe um
but
are you now able to kind of commiserate
a little bit more and connect with him
on that level like i kind of i get this
thing well i mean yes and no he's so
great he's given me such amazing advice
but i still feel like he's always had
movies in his head
whereas i'm just kind of starting to
learn how to create movies in my head
and speak that language
and speak the language and it's been
such a fun
new ride it's kind of bizarre to me i
i just never
thought i could love anything more than
theater and i love film just as much and
it is a shock to the system it's really
like i just you spend 22 years of your
life doing something and then you spend
five years doing something and it
doesn't feel
i thought i knew myself i thought i'd do
myself yeah i'm fascinated being by like
the fact that you couldn't just have the
nodes removed you had to teach yourself
to almost like speak above them they
don't want to do that especially like
when they don't have to and especially
with kids because kids are really they
heal much quicker than adults and you
can sort of um
because you're not fully formed yet like
as a body or as i mean obviously is the
mind as well but you can kind of
unlearn behavior and then relearn it
they caught it at a good time okay um
and sometimes the surgeries are not
you know
there's more risk so they wanted to
start with the speech therapy and the
and the voice therapy before
they attempted and see if it worked and
i'm so lucky that it did i never had to
to have anything surgically are you able
to go into that other
register the one that that was
troublesome are you able to speak like
yeah it's so funny i am so haunted by
that whole experience like any time i
lose my voice whether it was because
i don't know i was having fun and
enjoying a night like or i'm sick or
whatever it's like it feels like trauma
like it it it produces this fear that
i'll never be able to sing again and and
because of that i am not a very um
confident singer anymore which is a
really kind of interesting journey that
my friends and family are really helping
me with because they're like you were on
broadway and i was like i know but
but i'm not naturally an amazing singer
and it took so much work
and so much anxiety to kind of get me my
voice back and get all these things in
line that i don't know it really does
make me self-conscious i've never really
talked about it before but it's
something i really want to work on in
the same way that some people like i'm
really not plagued by body confidence at
all like i'm a naturally very
body confident person and i think i know
a lot of people that struggle with that
my thing is my singing like i can't
hear it i can't hear it the way it
sounds
i don't
i don't trust it i don't well
psychologically it makes total sense
that you don't want to like you said it
perfectly like you don't want to love it
too much because you then fear that you
may be losing it the fear that you may
be losing it uh one day it might go away
um i'm really this is like therapy
justin i i'm really learning so much do
this regularly
i would love it um well really quick i i
want to talk because uh you're doing
promotion you said for how to build a
girl and i was lucky enough to see it
you're so good in this bean fortunately
i'm not complimenting your singing i'm
just complimenting your acting so you
can take this compliment i'll try i'll
try it it's a true leading performance
you have to carry the movie i don't want
to give it away but it's it's kind of a
rock and roll coming of age story where
you get caught up in the world of
rock journalism and uh a little bit like
almost there's some almost famous
parallels
and the first thing that struck me was
your accent just how
how strong your accent was and you're
and the rest of the cast for the most
part great actors patty considine and
sarah sullivan oh just great great actor
but all british if i'm not mistaken
right entirely british casting for me
so how how do you get you have a dialect
coach uh did it it must have helped to
be around them but did you ever feel
intimidated to be in the midst of this
authentically british cast as an
american actor so it takes place in
wolverhampton basically
catelynn moran wrote the book that how
to build a girl is based on and adapted
the screenplay herself and it's also
very loosely based on her life so
my character johanna morgan is a
fictionalized version of catelyn but
catelyn has lived in london since she
was about 17. doesn't speak
anything like she spoke as a child
completely different because the second
um you move away from where you're
living yeah you're exposed to so many
different other accents that you sort of
morph and change and also she was
trying for a lot of at the beginning of
her career she didn't want people to
know she was from wolverhampton so she
would sort of
uh you know morph and change her put on
a more kind of
high brow london
exactly so
and in the uk accents are so linked to
identity in a way that i just
we could never really understand i mean
we do have like of course southern
and midwestern and like new york new
jersey long island has its own you know
thing going on so whatever hampton is
also of an in completely
underrepresented town in in british
media like it is either like the butt of
a joke it's just forgotten and it's left
behind and it's left out and catelyn is
such a
kind of triumphant success story of this
town
that
i felt so much pressure to get her
accent right oh yeah we knew that i had
to go to wolverhampton because the
accent just doesn't exist i mean
honestly youtube search it there's like
two videos of wolverhampton on the
internet wow um and so i knew i had to
go there and the director
came up with this crazy idea that i
should work in a store
in the town for a few weeks great that's
so cool
i worked in this store called the shop
in the square for almost three weeks i
shook hands with her and i looked her in
the eye and and promised her i would
speak in the accent the entire time i
was working
whether i was like talking to customers
or ordering
this is like a dream this is a dream
well it was also like as a sociology
major i was like i wish i had enough
time to write the ethnography of this
experience because this is so
fascinating yeah
but it was the most immersive thing i
have ever done and maybe we'll ever do
as an actor i mean it was so full on and
so unique and and magical and mystical
in some ways how long did you like work
regular hours there you worked all day
though yeah so i worked like wow seven
hour shifts or whatever and i would i
would help them restock it was this kind
of feminist utopia of a store it's all
of these local female artists that sell
their work in a cooperative style and so
i got to meet all these amazing it's
like porlandia literally yeah um
if i hadn't gone to wolverhampton it
would just be
southerners or northerners
guesses at what that really is and what
that feels like and what that sounds
like and their impression of what
wolverhampton is versus going there and
getting to be open and and create my own
impression of the city they recently
became a city only about 20 years ago
something i learned in my time there
used to be a town a wolverhampton trivia
oh there you go i kept saying town and
they were like we actually became the
city
and i was like i am so sorry um
and i went to caitlin's um the house
that she grew up in on on the council
where she grew up
and did it look like where they shot it
it's such great locations it's such like
the match the match for it was amazing
we were in watford um
it just outside of london to match the
exteriors of wolverhampton we did do one
day in wolverhampton like the scenes
where i'm running uh to the train
station or get hit with the book by the
kind of
oh that was great it's great because it
says the narration says and that's i
mean it's also funny then that's when it
hit me um yeah that in the beginning of
the bullies yeah i know the impact a
great book can have yes something to
note is that that was not supposed to it
was supposed to fly over my head and
on accident
are very it looked very natural prop
master threw it directly on my face and
thank god because he created such an
amazing moment yeah and it was allegedly
on accident uh yeah of course allegedly
um but it was it was a life-changing
experience in so many ways but i think
getting to create that that character
and
that creative team and cast and crew and
be welcomed so
openly by this
i mean it's a truly british story it is
it really is british and
and they took a chance on me and i i
feel so proud and lucky and and being
you probably can't talk much about
monica lewinsky because i know you
haven't shot it yet um but are you
watching a lot of footage while you're
home or is that how you're preparing
yeah you know i i really can't say
anything i'm sorry oh okay all right so
you can't say if you're preparing i'm
understanding you're walking
okay
you could guess that i am preparing over
there for a lifetime certainly all right
we're breaking this
this is the scoop
um yeah and and also what about mary lee
we rolling along you probably can't talk
much about that but that's richard
linklater is going to shoot over the
course of 20 years i read that is that
true 20 years boyhood was about 13 but
there is god
rick linklater is like i don't know i
just he just had a um a retrospective of
his work at the pompadou in paris and i
was with my family in paris over the
holidays and i went to it
it's one thing to watch his movies but
then to be inside all of them at one
time i just i don't know i got really
emotional
he's just and he's such a sweet
earnest man he's so thoughtful and kind
you must be very patient
is that true that it's going to be 20
years it's going to be 20 years yeah and
and ben and i have loved marylee our
entire entire lives um
we used to like sing it on the way home
from school
the nerdiness is gonna pay off
[Music]
this is a really quick lightning round
sorry i know we're going a little past
um
pass the time uh what is your most
commonly used emoji would you say i was
thinking about it because i know that i
had to be thinking about it and oh this
is a big one
it's a big one i think it's the girl
with one arm up like saying hey
hey here i am hey because it's kind of
like like nerdy and awkward it it loves
you specifically but then also anytime i
get a new friend's number i always like
say like hate speed like the little hey
it's like non-threatening it's innocent
yeah yeah these are all things i like to
convey too
maybe uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
gymnastics oh 100
i love gymnastics i couldn't do it if my
life depended on it but i have so much
admiration for it and i follow it i love
it
okay um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be
you know what my answer is is just
chocolate chips really yes me and my
best friends from wesleyan we would keep
chocolate chips and we'd sit around our
kitchen table at night and eat them
together and that was like our little
catch-up
time
with each other and just like so you
have a nice memory associated with yeah
and it's like continued into my adult
life now like the friends come into our
apartment they go straight for the
chocolate chips and this is a tough one
i know so
i i've been amending it what's your
favorite movie of all time or i could
say in quarantine what's a movie that
you feel has been so the most comforting
to really okay
so
i have two uh well just bridesmaids it's
just because yeah
i mean i actually haven't watched it in
quarantine yet but i've seen it probably
200 times like that's not an
exaggeration
i saw it my last week of high school
with all my best friends at midnight
and it's one of my favorite like movie
going experience memories
ever but all about friendship all about
friendship and i think it also just
showed me that like
women
funny women could be valued and like
beloved and celebrated in the same way
that
totally so many dude movies have
throughout my whole life and then get
nominated for oscars and all the give
women all these those all those women
opportunities beyond that and it just
yeah i don't know i think it just gave
me hope i was like wow if you had to
live somewhere else where would it be
london did you shoot in
yeah so we shot
99 in london and then just one day in
wolverhampton just because of like money
that's what we had to do um but my
girlfriend lives in london and so i'm
kind of long distance back and forth
between and
i love the uk i mean i mean i i think
i'm an honorary brit at this i don't
know if i can get myself that title but
between the girl and now my girlfriend
is well she's from liverpool she's a
scouser oh what a great accent
such a good accent i mean her brothers
when they're drunk and it's loud i'm
like i'm
every other word
front isn't it
it's all in the front
and you're like
that's funny it's so good how long have
you been dating her and is that
something that you talk about yeah well
you know we've been together almost two
years which is oh wow
we met working on how to build a girl
together
and uh she produced the movie she's the
best we call her the baby boss she's
like oh she's just a boss
about to be confused with boss baby not
to be confused with boss baby although
you know her dog bob would really have a
lot in common
um
that is who she reminds me of no just
kidding um that was my next question if
you were to date a baldwin brother
in a woman form who would it be
um you know here's the thing i
i'm so lucky to get to do what i do and
i am so
grateful and if i can just be open and
be myself in whatever kind of section of
my life that means and it can help
someone be closer to being open and
comfortable with them with their selves
is that the right english um
then that is is beautiful
and important to me in some way not to
get too on my high horse about it at all
but of course no i believe in being open
it's who i naturally am it's who i
intrinsically am
i love bond so much she's my favorite
just she's the best thing to happen to
my life and i was really inspired i was
listening to kristen bell's episode of
your show and and like her and dax are
so open about who they are in their
relationship and and i i don't know so
i'm kind of inspired by her i mean i'm
inspired by her in so many ways but yeah
i
with i'm just a naturally open person it
would feel against my character to be
closed off that's just not who i am but
i also think like if someone can i can
look at me on screen or i'm on whatever
instagram or whatever something like you
know like this and say like
you don't have to be a size two to be
worthy of you don't have to you know
even if it's my body or or my my who i'm
in love with or whoever like i yeah i
just it's better for it easier for me
and more natural to me to be open but i
also
have been so kind of in my life
as an adult and as a young person been
so grateful and inspired by
those that
that are open
and given opportunities like melissa
mccarthy
her whole career
is so inspirational to me in every way
because she is the most talented person
to exist but also i never got to see
women be funny and celebrated and
nominated for oscars and just fully who
they are and so for me it's like if i
could be that for someone else boy is
that a gift to me
it's important to me to just get to
openly celebrate her because i love her
so much bond yeah yeah but also like if
that can make someone feel a little more
comfortable with themselves or a little
more brave
then yeah that's a beautiful thing
yeah absolutely being well said i think
that's really beautiful and and
because unfortunately we live in a time
where it's people do still certainly in
parts of the this country struggle with
that you know so it's not we're not
there yet so if you can um if being open
means making it easier for somebody
that's really cool it's really admirable
to acknowledge like i am in the most
privileged position in so many walks of
life but specifically like i grew up in
a very progressive
open accepting community family uh city
uh
and religion and i
am so lucky because when i
fell in love with bond and discovered
like a different i always say like i'm a
late bloomer like it was this was never
something that i was sitting on and
didn't tell anyone and if that's your
story that is so valid and so important
and you should tell it but that is not
my story my story is not
this secret or this thing i understood
about myself that i wasn't ready to open
up and
tell that's not true
what is the real story is that i was
such a late bloomer i didn't think i'd
ever be in love i never cared about that
side of
romance or intimacy or anything like i
just didn't care
i
jonah used to call me dexter because he
was like you are abso like you are
literally
so mean and i see and you're the warmest
person in the world but when it comes to
like romance you're just like the ice
queen um you're fully like like
a serial killer of relationships and i
was he literally called me dexter i was
so cold yeah it was not something that i
was like throughout college being yeah
throughout college i just wow i
i
i loved and i have so much love for the
met specifically like my my boyfriend
that during college
i love him but i was i was not i
something was missing and then i met
bonn
and i was like this is what they [ __ ]
write songs about like oh my god i'm not
dexter but i just i didn't know
it was not something that i was closing
myself off to or not communicating it
was just something i had yet to do you
hadn't discovered it i was so you know
in my mid-20s like had yet to discover
so i also think that's an important
thing to share like the late bloomer
narrative is so underrepresented in oh
yeah art media it's like the second a
girl character turns 16 it's like or you
know it's like what's happening with the
virginity plot line like right exactly
and i was such a late bloomer and also
late bloomer and discovering like who i
love and who i am in that way
um
so i love you about that because i i
never saw that
well it's amazing being that that in
this exp you had this experience while
shooting this movie because for people
who haven't seen it the movie is all
about discovering that and discovering
love and
self-love too and
what an experience that must have been i
mean what a transformative
yes it was life-changing in many ways
that's great dean i'm so happy for you
people can't see this because we don't
record these i mean we don't put them up
but but you're like you've changed color
uh oh my god so
you're blushing you know it's really
nice to see i just so crazy about you
it's nice to see you so happy it's
really i love you i want you to meet
bond she's i love him
quarantined now but uh she's in
liverpool yeah with her family but um
one day one day soon yeah
yeah i might annoy her because
i you mentioned kristen bell i did chris
and i do a similar thing where we have a
hard time
not repeating what the person said in
their voice in their accent especially
when they have an accident and i love
she's listening to it yeah oh no please
guilty go for it go for it just give her
a heads up that's what i do no she'll
love it
uh if you could uh have dinner with
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met who would you pick carol king
okay
eleanor roosevelt
usually i would say steven sondheim but
i got to zoom in you got to meet him
yeah
but i got to meet him for a zoom call
does that count um yeah and maybe
shonda rhimes maybe there's there's
rhymes in there sure why not shonda
would be recording the whole thing and
wanting to make a
show out of it um which i would watch
that show
who's your favorite muppet bean
uh i think i know the answer to this
what do you think the answer is i would
say fozzie
oh
no i don't know i feel good about that
um if you could have one superpower what
would it be
oh i don't know if it's a superpower
because it's like
a harry potter magical power but to
operate like to just be like i want to
because i'm in a long distance
relationship i think that's where it
comes from but it's like i just want to
be
i hate flying so if i could just be like
me too i'm there snap my fingers and
somewhere else that would be great a
great gift
okay apparate um if you could be one age
for the rest of your life physically
what would you pick
it's tough to ask somebody who's so
young that question
that's a great question
i feel like it's going to be empowering
to be
i don't know like my late
30s early 40s yeah that feels like a
really like you're grounded you're like
you're less self-conscious you're like
all my friends that are that age are
like they just own who they are
they're very confident but then you
still have so much more of life to lead
i gotta say being i yeah i felt that way
over the last couple of years i felt a
lot more kind of there's a calm there's
a not needing to try as hard maybe yeah
i think i was just i'm reading amy
poehler's book again oh yeah yes please
and she's just
she's talking about how she used to want
to please people so much and and kind of
that's so who i i'm kind of stuck in
that phase now of like i'm just like
sure whatever you want walk all over me
like it's great
yeah sure i'll do your podcast
don't start with me you know i love you
like family and this is such a gift
and i love your podcast as a listener
i i am it's hard for me to kind of stick
up for myself
she talks about the kind of learning to
do that and she just gives great
examples of when she's done in her life
but yeah i think by that age i'll have
kind of re-grabbed that i had it as a
kid i was like so demanding and spunky
and yeah as you know um yeah but i think
i've lost that a little bit so i feel
like it should be a good a
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny oh unfunny totally yeah i
think the the the most kind of searing
for me would be like uh
not
not kind or like unkind yeah
yeah or she's not respectful
but yeah bean i think it's always what
you value the most and you clearly value
yeah um oh yeah i don't i don't care
um which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia oh
blanche
but yeah
i think
but blanche i always think of as like
just uh she's like a tennessee william
she's like a a good time charlie you
know she's like a good time it's kind of
dramatic like fabulous i don't know if i
like traumatic yeah if i identify as
much as i just like love people like i
mean i grew up with shay i think i just
love that yes
less i guessed identified and more just
sort of love to be around that type of
energy i agree yeah um which do you
prefer dogs or cats bean
oh i am
definitely allergic to cats i despise
them this is like this is one thing i
have a strong opinion on i am
okay yeah i fully
i i hate cats with every fiber of my
entire being because
they are they make me so sick
that i can't breathe and i won't listen
so
i um the hatred really began when cats
became allowed to fly on airplanes
because if a cat is on an airplane i
can't be on that airplane
and it is it's that you're that
sensitive yes and it is so i'm gonna
text you a photo of oh i guess i could
just show it to you oh i don't i want to
make sure the audio works okay yeah a
photo of i was once in a house that had
a cat but i never saw the cat i didn't
interact with the cat my face looks like
a filter like a
instagram
something like crazy distorted filter um
it's
i hate cats so much but it's because i'm
definitely allergic to them which i yeah
yeah
same thing
there are certain breeds of cats that i
found that i'm extremely allergic to to
the point where i
i
used to go out with this girl and i went
back to her house and
i i just lot like my face was had blown
up and i was sneezing and all that i was
like a cat you're sure you don't have a
cat she kept saying no
and then i was like oh there must be
something else i don't know what it she
goes i mean i had a cat
like months ago and so it must have been
still never
never
i'm a bit psychic in general but i have
like a sixth sense with
with that which is i once actually was
visiting jonah on
some
press thing or something and i walked
into this house and i said
do they have the cat and they're like
the previous owner had a cat six years
ago and i was like i have this is sick
this is like wow
but you're right
that [ __ ] doesn't go away that [ __ ] goes
nowhere it cleans
so i
the beatles is like her family and that
i love that city so much and um
yeah for sure the basil
um
what uh do you ever think about you're
so young it's it's silly to ask you this
but you ever think about your how you
want to be remembered um
what kind of legacy you want to leave
behind oh that's such a beautiful
question when we were filming had one
before we filmed how to build a girl as
you said it was like the first time i
ever was the only lead of a film i had
come straight out of book smart where
caitlin and i together got caitlyn
deaver the brilliant effervescent oh
she's so good yeah so good it's like
um
but we got to share this incredible
responsibility of leading you know but
for how to build a girl it was
it was my own kind of
it was my first time doing it alone and
i thought a lot about because i've been
so lucky to be
led by such brilliant
leaders in my career as like because
i've done so many kind of
um
just get get to learn from so many
people around me that i thought like
i kept thinking about their kind of
impact on me it's not legacy of course
but like their impact on me of like
sercia on lady bird was the most
giving generous spirited
just
force and and bet and all of these
people that i've been lucky enough to
work with and i just thought what do i
want them to remember me with
and i and i remember just saying like
it
i don't care if anyone thinks i'm a good
actor at the end of the day i don't even
i'll be able to sleep at night if i did
if i messed up a scene
but i will never be able to sleep if i
hurt someone or i didn't respect someone
and
for me it's just like being a good
conscientious respectful person but also
like person within society i always
want to make sure people are treated
equally and treated with respect
and that is what i want to be remembered
for i think being that's
so beautiful but i also think it uh not
to make it about your work but i i think
that radiates i think that comes across
in your performances i think that is um
thank you i like that you have that
ambition at such a young age um
and
you i'm just so happy for you being i
you mentioned book smart and i know a
lot of people compared that to super bad
uh and and obviously that like scene
where you go to
when caitlyn picks you up like there's
there's certain parallels but i i just i
found it so unique and different and i
love both movies but um i thought what
olivia was doing in that and you know i
just think that they're such different
movies and and
i i think what you do in that and
certainly in how to build a girl is uh
is really special and especially in a
way that is different than how special
jonah is so i'm proud of you for i love
you that means so much coming from you
yeah and you know how much i respect him
but i i'm telling you you're forging
your own path and it's it's a really
like it's so fun for me to watch you
travel that path and have success on it
so
yeah thanks for doing this pat it's good
to see your face
this is so good
um
send your whole family especially your
brother my love too because i will
thanks bean you're the best
proud of you
[Music]
so that's that's that happened
wait wait hold on a second oh wait what
oh well so that happened
oh sorry i'm not doing this fully sober
oh yeah that's right you you've had uh
you're a bud light seltzer deep i'm
i'm one bud light seltzer and so you're
on your second if i sound a little crazy
that's why yeah although um
i you know i had i thought we were
talking about this on the drive here i
had five bud light tilters stop stars
uh last night and didn't i mean i don't
know if i should be bragging about this
but i didn't really it was i felt like a
nice kind of
glow yeah yeah but you did so
responsibly yeah i didn't drive anywhere
i was watching a sunset i didn't even
interact with anyone they really go down
easily don't you yeah they do and
they're this is not an ad no we're no
they really do
we should be proud of that um this is
just us this is our lives
we're talking about our something we
enjoy uh anyway back to beanie something
else we enjoy
ah beanie how
isn't it surreal knowing just knowing
the way we knew her as a kid well not to
make it about me but uh it really makes
me feel old i know that she is not only
an adult number one i know but i know
that alone i haven't got
but such an accomplished thoughtful yeah
mature adult i know uh it's really
really makes me feel old you know what
phrase i hate which i almost said like
adulting when people say like i'm i'm
i'm getting the hang of this adulting
thing
i i don't like that either yeah you both
have to not like adulting
maybe i just don't like doing it either
i don't like what it means anyway uh
beanie's doing it very well she's
adulting like a champ she is um she is
definitely grown up and i think i was
thinking about this
is she our youngest guest that we've
ever had oh typically we have guests who
have a little bit more uh
miles under their belt that's not a
charm
it is i think um you're dancing around
yeah because you don't want to be
offensive yeah but people are older
why should that be offensive but it is
but i think part of elderly one of the
things you get from being older is
a bit of perspective on your life and
yeah you know i think it helps make a
conversation more interesting when
someone has a little bit more yeah um
you know yeah some experience but
good and bad but even though she i think
she's our youngest guest she's really
only a good she's had a lot of good
she's had i will say she is remarkably
um thoughtful and she has a really
mature
sense of perspective on her young life
yeah you know yeah and i think a lot of
that comes from
and i think this is rare
when people have
um very clear
goals and very clear a very clear sense
of themselves and their identity and
what they and what their passions are
and i think she is an example of someone
who from you know
birth basically has been
very aware of who she is and what she
loves to do yes and has a confidence
that belies
her years
is that
i couldn't i couldn't weigh in until you
finish the sentence
belies her years right um
yeah i think that's like saying it it
runs counter exactly um young but she
has a more mature perspective but she as
as buoyant and i'm the way we described
her as you know bubbly is there's
something condescending about the word
bubbly i'm trying to avoid saying that
but as that as she was as a kid yeah
bubbly i think can be misinterpreted
yeah like um who would be bubbly like
like suzanne summers and three's company
great reference yeah exactly although
that character did so or betty white's
character rose in uh
golden girl i don't think she's so ditzy
i think she's more uh
dim
dim than tits oh yeah um
harebrained no but anyway beanie is uh
beanie has always been even as a kid
which is how i knew her better
she had a tremendous amount of
confidence you know yeah like like an
unusual amount of confidence for a kid
i'll never forget meeting her she and
charming and present but again i don't
think it's confidence in what she was
doing i think it was more confidence in
knowing that she loved
doing what she was doing you know what i
mean i think there's different she
talked about that she doesn't have
she has insecurities about her her
singing oh of course yeah that surprised
me in fact because as like you said as a
person
um she is so
con she just strikes me as somebody who
doesn't question her behavior or i mean
not in a bad way yeah really good and
really admirable it was funny when you
were because the last time i saw her was
i maybe the last time you saw her in
person we
ran into her in new york at a restaurant
with eating lunch with her mom and ben
platt yeah and we had not seen dear evan
hansen yet but i knew who he was and he
you know he had i knew he had some juice
you know people were talking about him
he was at seymour's
new york place that's right i didn't
know him either and and
wait what were you gonna say well i was
gonna say i i was struck then by
how um
grown up she was and also i i was gonna
make fun of you for
because we we had uh we ended up seeing
ben platt's play and had we seen it
before meeting him i would have been
like a nervous
mess around him i'm so in awe of that
person you are i should save it for uh
hopefully a future ben i know
but in when you were talking to beanie
she was talking about going to wesleyan
and you very confidently said and that's
where you met ben platt all right like i
don't know why you were so sure that she
was like actually i met him uh in high
school oh oh why did i think that it's
funny when you go in really confidently
yeah uh ladies and gentlemen
changed everything yeah because that is
when you met ben yeah well because i'm
so i'm not very often that confident
it's funny to be wrong and like super
confident and super wrong at the same
time confident nerds are a funny thing
that i notice um there was a guy
yesterday who was who did a confident
nerdy oh at the dumpty
christian i go
at the dump near where i live in
massachusetts there's a there was a guy
who
has this confident
he's like a nerdy author we go there to
dump garbage but oh yeah we don't go
there it's a chill yeah
um it's a great spot to meet people um
but he he
i asked him like i held up some garbage
and i was like is this recycling or
garbage and i want to know if i should
put it in this receptacle and he just
gave me this is maybe a more visual
thing but he just gave me this
very like nerdy like condescending
point it was like
like he didn't say anything but if he
had it would have been like
right in there yeah a lot of shame in
that point yeah
yeah
um
yeah but ben platt oh so ben but yeah
you're right had we and we saw it i
think i think we
got in touch
sharon feldstein her mom who was at that
lunch i think was like oh my god you
have to uh because she's the one that
saw us and was like you got to come in
and see beanie and oh ben platt is there
and you know ben platt and we were like
don't really christian was like yeah
i've heard of him and she so we had this
nice lunch with them and ben was very
sweet and he was great to catch up with
her and then when they left um sharon
was like oh my god you have to see you
have to see dear evan hansen and
christian had wanted to see it and so
she got us these tickets
yeah sharon really hooked that up so a
couple days later we saw it and you know
the rest is my brain melted yeah
and i haven't stopped thinking about it
since
um and yeah her i like her relationship
with her mom they're very uh
they're like best friends yeah it's
really nice it and it reminded me of
when
we lived with jonah how he would refer
to his parents his roommates as his
roommate he's like
his ex-roommates
yeah but but like i know he was kidding
but there's something about their that
family's dynamic yeah
they all genuinely seem to like you
they're really friendly with each other
i know that's a weird thing to say about
family but often i think that's a rarer
thing than uh then it sounds like that a
family should have such good friends and
they also don't seem to really
let age get in the way of their
friendships with each other
so that's why i mean it's funny that he
called them roommates but in a way
that's it seems like how they see each
other yeah they're all kind of
equal even when i talked to bini about
being in because she had been in
quarantine for a while she had been
in the lockdown in l.a and i was like oh
how is it with rich and sharon and kind
of like fishing for some dirt about like
how annoying it might be to live with
them spend some money and she was like
you know they're great i mean
it seemed like she was
into it
yeah their parents sound very similar to
our parents in in that they're very
different
but they you know exactly a way to make
it work so rich the dad is a lot more is
like our dad a lot more stoic and you
know cerebral which is not to say he you
know
and then sharon's just a lot like our
mom a lot
more outgoing and you know sociable
yeah um
oh the richard linklater movie i forgot
she was doing that yeah
20 years right now is crazy crazy
but she seems like a good person
for him to have picked for that role
because sodas
exactly because neither of them seem
like they're going anywhere number one
right in terms of their careers they're
like on this upward trajectory but they
also seem so passionate about what they
do that it's not like at year 17 they're
like you know what
i don't want to be an actor anymore
gonna go through something else yeah
that's right they're perfect for those
roles yeah i remember when didn't we
talk about this like what what happens
if you cast somebody in that and they're
like who knows what's gonna change in 20
years what if they're like i want to go
be an accountant yeah
yeah
i mean people leave acting all the time
or it gets to be especially acting
because it's such a grind but she's
always loved it it was funny yeah she
was talking about
how she like literally can't remember a
time where she
didn't want to be a musical theater on
broadway and and it's at a certain point
you were like oh so when in high school
or college did you make the decision to
pursue acting and she was like always
i've always wanted to do it like right
out of the womb so incredulous yeah i
could picture her like right out of the
world just like hello i'm a baby hello
my honey
someone get this placenta off me
hey are you my mom where's my dad is he
oh man
are you imagining a little infant in a
little i am with a top hat and a cane
yeah hey let's read a letter okay okay
all right let's do the top one this one
from ben uh-oh
don't you don't you really want him to
listen to the show more than anything
you're like you're just like i'm getting
flushed
remember we were watching this the
celebrity watch party thing and we
realized that there were like three more
of them there were other plats that were
that their voices were just as angelic
there's like generations of plats
yeah that kid is just incredible okay
this is from ben
letter from a teacher dear justin and
kristen dodgeball came out when i was in
high school speaking of feeling old and
at the time i looked so much like justin
that classmates
i didn't know at my large high school
began to approach me and asked me when i
had filmed the movie oh my god i started
listening to your podcast on a tip from
one of your remote producers
shouts to mike moody in austin ah moody
yeah we love moody moody owns um a bunch
of fun bars down there anyway uh because
i am the mohawk if you've ever been
because i had enjoyed quite a few of
your roles in my formative years
recently as i began driving more from
meetings and planning to return to
teaching maybe this fall i've started
digging back through your older episodes
with guests i'd initially skipped over
luis guzman was an episode i ignored i
think in part because of the roles he
has played it had caused me to make
assumptions about him as a
one-dimensional person huh chelsea
handler was another i didn't think i'd
enjoy because i was not at all familiar
with her work perhaps this is a nice
life reminder that everyone has their
story and deserves a chance to be heard
that's really cool ben yeah um yeah what
a great letter yeah and he has some
would you rather it's great
would you rather be a ghostbuster
meaning deal with some [ __ ] up stuff
but still be able to clock out or a
superhero with cool powers but always on
the clock ah that's a good question
that is really good
um
you know
i i never consider the superhero
question with uh uh the the negative
aspects of it i never no you haven't no
i think i'm lazier than you i always
think about how annoying it must be to
always have to respond to the bat signal
if it comes oh no no i don't mean that i
don't mean to like being a famous one
just i just mean one that has these
powers so like in other words if you
could see through things let's say if
you had x-ray vision is it always on
like can you turn it off oh see i i i
don't think that's what he's asking
though he's saying he's making it
workload yeah yeah would you would it be
incumbent on you to always do something
yeah
uh i would pick
just because
he's not specific about i'm too lazy
about what cool powers means so i'm
imagining like yeah cool powers you can
fly you can
you know i'm gonna say super superman
okay yeah um i would it's a lot of
responsibility i don't know a lot of
responsibility and we'd be terrible
super terrible
like you would like i wouldn't be
terrible if i had the powers what are
you talking about i'm saying your work
ethic no offense we both have bad you
know both have their bad work ethics but
like think about us writing a script how
long it takes to like just like write
something
i'm imagining you like you see the like
whatever your version the bat signal is
the christian oh see i'm imagining if if
i had superpowers like commissioner
gordon
you're like super x-ray vision
all the super things i think i would
also with that i would get
super motivation
oh so i i think i would uh a different
work ethic than i have now do you think
superman had a terrible workout i'm not
saying that but compared to superman
he's always he doesn't have but you
can't be on the clock but but i would if
i had to that's the point so would you
anyone would if they had um that i'm
saying like it would now the way if you
frame it like that it sounds like a
burden to have these powers it does it
also sounds like a burden to be a
ghostbuster and a lot no no ghostbusters
fun you got like you have the packs and
you do the thing as long as you don't
you know there are certain rules you
have to follow but like it's like being
an exterminator
i'm sure that's a very do you know scary
being a ghost but you're thinking of
scary you're thinking of uh like a
cartoon you're of slimer are you
thinking of real ghostbusters i'm trying
to
what's scary about it what's the
scariest you have to deal with these
haunted places all the time you have uh
you have ecto whatevers that can you
have
you have the tools to deal with it it's
you just point it i never understood why
that was why that should be so scary i
mean it's scary only because it's scary
you still have to walk into one of these
old haunted houses and deal with i
wouldn't be that scared if i had a pack
of stuff that like could zap a ghost and
to put put one in a containment unit all
right well i guess we're both we're both
saying we'd rather be ghostbusters than
superheroes for different reasons
because we're lazy basically
um
all right uh you want to finish the
letter yeah um okay sorry ben i enjoy
the show and how your genuine
conversations humanize your fellows and
show business ben the teacher what a
great thank you ben uh i really
appreciate that and that's
and i agree with him you know i i've had
that experience with certain people that
i've i've just seen their names on
podcasts and thought i i kind of know
who that is yeah i can i can understand
making an assumption about somebody like
louis guzman um who then you know turns
out to be
he's got fullest
he's got a lot of depth
yeah speaking of shows christian and i
are uh procrastinating writing we're
supposed to be writing something uh for
and with louis at the moment uh which
has been a really fun experience we're
just dragging our feet anyway so thank
you to ben the teacher i i also like how
you call yourself ben the teacher yeah
um i think we should all do that didn't
they used to do that today yeah like
bart'll be the scrivener like joseph the
shepherd yeah
yeah i like that justin the podcaster
yeah
that's a little that doesn't sound as
good as ben the teacher but um justin
the part-time ghostbuster
[Laughter]
yeah cause well also ghostbusting you'd
probably that sounds like it might be a
full-time job too i mean if you get a
call at three in the morning if you see
a ghost then it's like coming out i
think you could schedule i think it's a
40 hour a week job
i i think they were always getting calls
uh what's her face um annie potts so
good in that movie
annie potts where ghostbusters what's
your emergency
is that good it's good
ghostbusters
now you didn't get any calls well thanks
again to ben and thanks again to beanie
feldstein for being our guest
and um thanks to ben platt dude just for
existing yes thanks to ben plan and
thanks to jonah for having a cool sister
and helping shape her i'm sure yeah um
and sharon and sharon and rich yeah
that's the whole feldenstein clan yeah
they're the best and uh
and and we love them so and if you guys
want to write into the show our email
address is life is short at wondery.com
life
could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it is produced by you christian long and
also megan monaco senior producers
michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marcia louis and
hernan lopez for
wondering
um stay tuned for a very very special
voice memo brought to you
by bud light seltzer
[Music]
bud light seltzer
what do you think are you recording
strawberry jealous
are you jealous yeah i am a little
jealous i'm not recording it looks
really cold too
ice cold can i try one no
why get your own you don't want a little
remnants of food on that no this is all
mine
the coldest
and guess what why only 100 calories hey
guys when they say enjoy responsibility
what do they mean
to be responsible don't drive don't
don't operate a plane or a blimp heavy
machinery
don't cause a fight but don't cause a
fight yeah all those things don't be an
idiot so is it fair to say we're
enjoying responsibly right now
yeah we're just sitting here watching
the sunset yeah birds you hear the birds
yeah enjoy responsibly we're not chasing
the birds and heiser bush saint louis
missouri missouri
you